welcome back now England are preparing
for their World Cup quarterfinal Clash
against early tournament favorites
France taking place this evening so can
England win well joining me now is the
former Leeds United and England
footballer Danny Mills Danny Mills good
to see you this afternoon now I know
you've played in a World Cup uh back in
2002 you got to the quarterfinals how do
you think they'll be feeling
I think there'll be an air of excitement
uh they'll of course be a touch of
nerves but I think what they will
realize that we thought against when we
played Brazilian in 2002 if you win this
game if you beat the world champions you
have a fantastic opportunity of going on
to reach the final and then of course
you know who knows what can happen so I
think it's all about this game get
through this game win this game and I'm
pretty confident even we'll get to the
final
oh well that would be amazing wouldn't
it um you've probably seen some of the
footage of them in training ahead of
this match they don't look nervous
no I mean it's it's a bit of a cliche
but you're very much sort of focused and
tunnel vision uh Kyle Walker all of the
chat chat has been about and bappa and
on the other side uh Luke Shore against
dembele death and Rise Against griezman
Midfield as a player you're very very
focused on first and foremost do your
job win your one-on-one battle and then
you think well if I do a good job then I
can start to help out my teammates and
then maybe I can do something else
perhaps going forward or if you're an
attacker defensively so you become quite
selfish to start with uh but I think the
biggest feeling is is you don't want to
let anybody down you don't want to be
the player to miss that chance miss that
penalty to give the goal away so you're
incredibly focused at this point uh
excited a little bit uh but more you're
just like I just want to do a very very
good job now when we last saw them play
against Senegal they were a little bit
tentative weren't they at the start of
the match they're not going to be able
to do that against France are they 'll
be moments in the game where France has
some very very good players uh
world-class players we know that
everybody is going to have to play well
Jordan Pickford will become very very
important there'll be three or four
moments where you know he'll need to
make big saves this is not going to be
an easy game um it's going to be very
very close I think it'll be to and fro
right until the very very end every
single player in that England side and
those that come off the bench need to
step up they need to have one of the
best performances that they've ever had
in England shirt and if they do that
I've got every conference that will win
and Danny who do you think has been the
player of the England side so far I mean
you were mentioning there the the
substitutes bench I mean they got had
some pretty good performances from some
of the people coming off the bench
haven't we I think what's really good
about this England setup in this England
squad maybe apart from Harry Kane you
could probably replace every single
player in that side with somebody in the
squad or somebody off the bench and it
doesn't necessarily weaken the team too
much this is very much I think about the
team whereas in the past you know we
we've hung our hat on Paul gascoigne on
Wayne Rooney and we've been so reliant
on one player to play well it's been a
little bit of a problem yes Harry Kane's
important but we've seen other players
score goals I think this team this squad
is the best team and the best Squad that
we've had as a collective for some time
and that gives me you know that gives me
a lot of Hope going into this game
yeah I mean it's still a big challenge
ahead of them France are of course
defending uh Champions is it significant
that a lot of the England squad they
either play together or against each
other in the Premier League which is not
the case for a lot of the French team
that camaraderie is very very important
understanding each other you don't get a
lot of time to work together when you're
an international team you know normally
people talk about playing a high press
and playing a particular way you can
only do that if you are working every
single day day in day out for weeks on
end an international manager doesn't get
that opportunity to work with the
players for that long knowing each other
having understanding of each other is
absolutely vital they've just got
they're all good players they've played
in under 17 World Cups under 20 World
Cups they've played deep into Champions
League games a lot of these players now
are experienced at knockout football
that is going to be absolutely vital but
first and foremost they've all got to
step up they've got to work as hard if
not harder than every single player in
that French team and then they've got to
rely on their quality to come through
and hopefully that'll be enough well I
hope the boys have heard that uh Danny
just a final thing where are you going
to be watching and what do you predict
the score line to be I'm gonna be sat at
home uh watching this uh probably biting
nails all the way through with my
England hat on I'm going to go England
2-1 but if I sit on the fence and become
a neutral this is the game I think this
is the closest quarter final of them all
this could go either way I I could make
an argument for France winning this two
one I could make it a game for England
winning this 2-1 so but I'm gonna go
with heart I'm gonna go with one two one
all right as long as it's not penalties
I don't think we could take that let's
hope not really good to talk to you
Danny enjoy the match thank you